das corona virus hat deutschland
erreicht und einen jungen mann in bayern
infiziert der kontakt zu einer chinesin
hatte die
patienten quasi allein da sind wir als
fremder die dem patienten in den letzten
atemzügen begleiten wir werden in der
politischen debatte und auch in der
medialen debatte nach dieser corona lage
alle miteinander viel verzeichnen müssen
26 wochen lockdown 269 tage home office
pflicht fünf gewinner wählen fünf
besorgniserregende varianten alpha beta
gamma delta und omikron und allein 2020
ist unsere lebenserwartung um knapp 300
monate gesunken und das schlimmste mehr
als 100 39.000 menschen sind an oder mit
corona gestorben das ist die bilanz aus
200 jahren corona panini eine ziemlich
bittere auch weil eine menge fehler
gemacht wurden und deswegen fragen wir
uns heute was hat die politik daraus
gelernt ich bin aminata berlin
willkommen bei context elefant tiefe
zusammenhänge und gramm fundstücke aus
dem zdf archiv aus
krone was hat die politik gelernt um das
zu beantworten schauen wir sind dieser
folge drei punkte an bei den ziemlich
viel schief gelaufen ist nämlich masken
gesundheitssystem und politische
kommunikation erster punkt masken mit
diesem produkt wurden millionen verdient
umstrittene massen geschäfte und
zahlreiche affären um unions abgeordnete
haben für ordentlich wirbel gesorgt
in der affäre um die beschaffung von
schutzmasken zieht sich der
cdu-abgeordnete nikolas löbel aus der
politik zurück es ist ein schlag ins
gesicht aller über 500 1000
parteimitglieder von cdu und csu wenn
sich einzelne versuchen an der pandemie
zu bereichern der ebenfalls verdächtige
csu politiker georg nüßlein ist bisher
nur aus der fraktion ausgetreten hier
ging es um provisionen in millionenhöhe
und massive private bereicherung auf
kosten der steuerzahler und das alles
während einer globalen ausnahme
situation
nicht nur einige politiker innen auch
private unternehmer innen haben davon
profitiert erst kürzlich entzauberte jan
böhmermann für das zdf in klima eine der
bekanntesten influenza deutschlands
100.000 falsche masken sind vollzählig
hier logistik klappt dann her damit
bitte aber so moralisch verwerflich
diese maske dienst waren die grundlage
dafür hat die politik selbst gelegt da
vorrat an medizinischen massen im
frühjahr 2020 war zu knapp die not war
ziemlich groß war der weltbestzeiten sie
sind teuer und sie sind knapp und wir
müssen ziemlich archaische methoden
verwenden um wie diese knappheit damit
umzugehen lieferengpässe leer gefegte
lager und dramatische preissteigerungen
lieferten einen fruchtbaren boden für
krumme geschäft dabei hätte der staat
den mangel voraussehen können aus
risikoanalysen bei der regierung bereits
bekannt das ist im falle einer pandemie
zu engpässen kommen könnte laut
nationale pandemiepläne land die
verantwortung für die bevorratung zwar
bei den krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen
um dieser pflicht nachkommen zu können
hätten sie aber rechtzeitig gewahrt
werden müssen da habe ich gesagt okay
das wird kritisch daraufhin habe ich im
fünften februar dem herrn sparen
gesundheitsminister einen brief
geschrieben und ihn gebeten diese lage
zu überprüfen die antworten die antwort
war gar keine erst mitte märz 2020
schaltet sich das gesundheitsministerium
endlich ein um die versorgungslücke zu
schließen und diese janko wird aber nur
leider menschenleben gekostet und das
ist schlimm und da müssen wir noch eine
menge lernen und was hat die politik
daraus gelernt die ursachen für den
masken notstand waren mangelnde vorräte
sowie die abhängigkeit von ausländischen
importen deswegen wollte bund die
sogenannte nationale reserve
gesundheitsschutz auf und will die
vorräte aufstocken das import problem
sollte durch eigene deutsche
produktionskapazitäten gelöst werden der
massen verband deutschland beklagt
allerdings dass die behörden aus
kostengründen trotzdem noch in china
bestellen statt hier produzieren zu
lassen kommen wir zum zweiten punkt die
angespannte lage des deutschen
gesundheitssystems
es handelt sich ja um eine
atemwegserkrankung damit können wir
grundsätzlich umgehen im
gesundheitswesen aber zu viel auf einmal
das ist natürlich denn das problem zu
viel auf einmal hat ja meistens etwas
mit guter planung zu tun wir hatten aber
zu wenig nicht an betten oder sauerstoff
sondern vor allen dingen an personal
haben hier viel dramatik gefährliche
sehen der ehemann und die ehefrau war
sie innerhalb von ein paar wochen
nebeneinander verstorben sind ist es
auch wirklich langsam auch für uns nicht
mehr
oder auch so mit unseren ethischen
verständnis unserer körperlichen
belastbarkeit
vereinbar unsere einer der wenigen
punkten tage wo kein patient gestorben
als die glocken läuten halt nicht gerade
dabei ist der mangel an pflegekräften
kein neues problem wir können das
problem seit langem in vielen
krankenhäusern besteht ein akuter
pflegenotstand quarantänebestimmungen
und krankheitsbedingte ausfälle haben
die situation während apple mit
zusätzlich verschärft aber hat die
politik daraus gelernt wie man es nimmt
bis ende des jahres soll endlich der
pflege bonus ausgezahlt werden und im
september tritt das achtung
bürokratendeutsch
gesundheitsversorgung
weiterentwicklungsgesetz in kraft das
wortungetüm soll den pflegeberuf
attraktiver machen durch tarifliche
entlohnung und eine personal untergrenze
in der intensivmedizin das problem im
moment fehlen in deutschland 8000
intensiv pflegekräfte und im schnitt
dauert s 21 wochen um eine solche stelle
zu besetzen der personalmangel in der
pflege bleibt also auf jeden fall thema
wenn ihr mehr dazu sehen wollt klickt
hier auf die infokarte da haben wir auch
eine ganze kontext folge nur zum thema
pflegenotstand verlinkt dritter punkt
die widersprüchliche kommunikation der
politik was war eine eigenartige aktion
war zum beispiel das hier gleichwohl
weiß ich natürlich dass dieser gesamte
vorgang zusätzliche verunsicherung
auslöst das bedauere ich zutiefst und
dafür bitte ich alle bürgerinnen und
bürger um verzeihung der usa lag da und
er dann doch nicht kamen oder die
schnelltests die sich verspäteten ein
ständiges hin und her dass für viel
misstrauen gesorgt und die frage
aufgeworfen hat ob die politik
eigentlich weiß was sie tut im februar
diesen jahres äußerten rund 41 prozent
der befragten in einer forsa-umfrage
dass sie wenig oder sehr wenig vertrauen
in das handeln der regierung während der
korona pandemie haben wie ist es bei
euch habt ihr noch vertrauen in die
korona politik schreibt es mir in die
kommentare krassestes beispiel die
kommunikation rund um impfen und
impfstoffe für wen und wann welcher
impfstoff wie häufig mit pflicht oder
ohne die antworten auf diese fragen
veränderten sich ständig aufgrund einer
aktuellen empfehlung des paul ehrlich
instituts setzt die bundesregierung die
krone impfung mit astra zyniker
vorsorglich aus und dann nur einen tag
später das festgestellte risiko einer
sehr seltenen hirn venenthrombose wird
weiterhin als gering angesehen als die
folgen die nicht impfen hat damit eine
impfstoff von astrazeneca plötzlich für
alle da das also unabhängig von alter
oder vorerkrankungen jeder der mit astra
zenica geimpft werden möchte auch
geimpft wenn k
aber der bank im stoff wurde aufgespart
das hätten wir klarer noch kommunizieren
müssen aber wir haben eben mit moderner
eine gute genauso wirksame alternative
also die entscheidende botschaft des
impfstoff ist genug da und bei den alten
vorgaben hat sich andauernd etwas
geändert die kogit 19 maxim als basilika
für personen im alter über 60 jahre zu
verwenden menschen unter 30 sollen
künftig nur noch mit dem impfstoff von
ba landtag meiser gegen korona geimpft
werden ein ergebnis dieses ganzen chaos
die impfquote liegt immer noch unter 80
prozent und die frage wie viele
impfungen und eigentlich braucht um
vollständig geschützt zu sein ist auch
nicht beantwortet viele haben
diesbezüglich auf den jetzigen
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
gesetzt schließlich hatte der sich zu
beginn der pandemie auch durch seine
klaren analysen hervorgetan also
dynamisch bedeutet also dass wir so am
anfang der epidemie stehen dass wir
deutlich mehr fälle erwarten müssen das
war bevor er minister wurde denn leider
hat auch lauterbach in seiner bisher
kurzen amtszeit entscheidungen wieder
zurücknehmen müssen sogar am selben tag
also diesem punkt also dass die
infizierten
dass die sich sagen wir selbst isolieren
und nicht mehr durch das gesundheitsamt
aufgefordert werden gehen werde ich
wieder einkassieren und dann war da noch
seine warnung vor der killer variante
daraufhin wurde ihm der vorwurf gemacht
panik und corona history zu schüren ja
der begriff also vielleicht nicht
optimal gewählt aber er hat es ja
zugespitzt nicht optimal so könnte man
auch die kommunikation während der
korona krise bezeichnen wohlwollen
ausgedrückt anders gesagt die alte
bundesregierung hat einen scherbenhaufen
hinterlassen die neue noch mehr scherben
draufgelegt dabei hat alles damit
angefangen es ist ernst nehmen sie es
auch ernst seit der deutschen einheit
nein seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gab es
keine herausforderung an unser land mehr
bei der es so sehr auf unser gemeinsames
solidarisches handeln ankommt angela
merkel mit ihrer ansprache vier tage vor
dem ersten lockdown um was hat die
politik seit ihm gelernt nach dem was
wir uns angeschaut haben zu wenig und zu
spät beispiel masken wahrscheinlich
werden wir bis zu ermöglichen weil im
herbst genügend davon haben aber ob für
die dann noch brauchen weiß niemand denn
vorher brauchen wir erst einmal ein
neues
infektionsschutzgesetz es war auf der a
93 9 punkte aus und dann wird die fahrer
erneut zu diskutieren sein also ob zum
beispiel masken tragen den innenräumen
wieder verpflichten würden und teile der
fdp signalisieren schon jetzt dass es
diesmal mit ihm schwieriger werden
könnte die wahrscheinlichkeit ist also
groß dass im ernstfall politisch wieder
nicht schnell genug reagiert werden kann
und das passt ins bild im pflegebereich
wird nur an den ganz kleinen schräubchen
gedreht stadt an den großen
stellschrauben und in sachen
kommunikation mangelt es nach wie vor an
klarheit und stringenz dass die
politisch verantwortlichen kam aus den
eigenen fehlern gelernt haben darunter
leiden im zweifelsfall wieder diejenigen
am meisten die diese krise eh schon
besonders schwer getroffen hat familien
alte kinder und risikopatientinnen
manchmal ist das gefühl als wenn die
decke auf mich feld unterbrachte thema
und ich habe ja niemand
die angst dass mit corona so weitergeht
dass man halt auf sich alleine gestellt
ist und ich merke das auch bei meinen
freunden den geht es auch mit der
situation echt nicht so gut es ist halt
einfach schwierig für alle ich denke
dass viele menschen das einfach gar
nicht so nachempfinden können wie sich
diese angst anfühlt wenn es tatsächlich
definitiv um leben und tod geht ich hab
würfel im leben mitgemacht aber dies
sind die einsamkeit
[Musik]
schlimm ist für oma wenn noch andere
gesichter pandemie sehen wollt schaut
euch die ganze doku in der zdf mediathek
an wenn ihr euch weiter mit dem thema
impfen beschäftigen wollt klickt hier
auf das video von unseren kolleginnen
von 13 fragen lust auf noch mehr kontext
hier geht es um unsere rente und
natürlich nicht vergessen unseren kanal
zu abonnieren und die glocken läuten